[Music]
i'm in los angeles at the elf on the
shelf
magical holiday journey where i'm going
to talk to some people and really quiz
them on their ho
ho holiday knowledge and to be safe i
brought look
a six foot candy cane microphone can you
name
all of santa's reindeer rudolph basher
prancer that's it truth i totally can't
name all the reindeer either so i
wouldn't know if he did it right or
wrong
rudolph donner blitzen vixen
dancer prancer lindsay lohan blitzen
splitter or blipster i don't remember
one of them
doesn't really matter rudolph rudolph of
course
cupid is probably one of them right
you said prancer back here we got a
prancer in the back dasher and dancer
prancer and vixen comet cupid donner
blitzen
and rudolph i feel completely vindicated
yes we have a winner ladies and
gentlemen
what do you want for christmas have you
decided i ride horses so i want a horse
saddle
and you have an actual horse to put it
on when i was your age i was like
begging for my little pony and you have
an actual horse
this is amazing i want
oh my god can i adopt him
what are you gonna get your mom for
christmas love and a nice cozy sweater
you're good
jayden you are good sally i hope santa
brings you something
she's like i'm sally sally
know your angles that's it sell it
good anything you'd like to say to
america
couldn't have said it better myself
thank you sally what's your favorite
holiday movie home alone
a christmas story hello i got the leg
lamp and everything probably elf
oh el such a good one right this home
alone cat home alone
totally counts that's the most
successful holiday movie of all time so
can you all do your best macaulay culkin
for me
one two three
the santa claus the santa the one with
tim allen yes
or die hard die hard no okay just
because it is set during christmas does
not make it a christmas movie
die hard cut i'm out
i can't work like this i quit
[Music]
you